Давайте сегодня поговорим о секретах
того как ведут свои переговоры э
сильнейшие люди этого мира политики
миллиардеры знаменитости и так далее при
этом большинство из них я бы сказал 99%
из них не осознают что они неосознанно
применяют эти принципы Конечно я понимаю
не каждый со мной согласится и не Многие
хотят это слышать но к сожалению мы
должны считаться с реальностью и мы
должны считаться А с законами этой
реальности закон этой реальности
достаточно суровый и первый закон
который я хотел бы вам сказать и который
является в основе любых э переговоров
это то что миром правит сила Вы можете
здесь со мной поспорить сказать что
миром правят законы миром правят мораль
общественные нормы религии и так далее и
так далее да это звучит правильно но на
самом деле миром правит сила и тому есть
множество примеров когда сильные страны
могут себе позволить делать то что не
могут себе позволить слабые страны Хотя
вроде бы есть ООН есть общие законы и
правила международные но сильным странам
дозволено больше чем слабым то же самое
можно взять в любом обществе Посмотрите
на политиков миллиардеров знаменитости и
так далее как бы закон не пытался их
уравнять всё равно они выходят зачастую
сухими из либо всё равно им дозволено
больше чем простым людям почему это так
происходит Дело в том что Сила
маскируется под законы мораль религию
общественные нормы и так далее Если вы
хотите быть успешными в этой жизни то я
думаю в ваших интересах себе это усвоить
что миром правит сила это основа для
того чтобы вести успешные переговоры и
понимать кто победит или выиграет в
переговорах после того Как вы себе
глубоко усвоить этот закон что миром
правит сила дальше будет легче вам
понять какая сторона в переговорах
возьмёт вверх приведу простой пример
представьте себе такую ситуацию что в
Фае какой-то гостиницы сидят
разговаривают два человека Один из них
миллиардер один из них миллионер Кто в
этих переговорах победит и кто кому
сделает уступку я думаю большого секрета
не будет здесь вы все понимаете что
скорее всего миллионер уступит
миллиардеру это яркий пример
того что миром правит сила и вот здесь
мы приходим к важному вопросу если миром
правит сила то у кого сила и как её
можно приобрести и здесь я хотел бы вам
открыть как раз-таки те Семь секретов
которыми неосознанно пользуется сильный
мира сего политики миллиардеры и
знаменитости друзья приглашаю
действующих бизнесменов и инвесторов в
уникальные шествие со мной по Бразилии
мы вместе проведём 9 дней в составе
группы из че человек таких же как вы
успешных бизнесменов и инвесторов Я
проведу там мастер май где разберу
стратегии вашей жизни и поделюсь с вами
своими практическими инструментами как
организовывать свою жизнь и
масштабировать свой бизнес места
ограничены поэтому спешите занять своё
место под бразильским солнцем ссылка
внизу в описании первое сила у того кто
меньше всего заинтересован в результате
то есть вот сидят две стороны в
переговорах и сила у того кто меньше
заинтересован в результате простой
пример Представьте в Фае гостинице сидит
а буддийский монах к нему приходит
помощник миллиардера и говорит Вот мой
шеф хотел бы с вами познакомиться на что
этот буддийский монах говорит Ну если он
хочет познакомиться Пускай подходит Я же
здесь и как вы думаете кто к кому
подошёл миллиардер Подошёл к монаху
чтобы познакомиться И это иллюстрирует
Наш первый принцип сила у того кто
довольствуется малым а малым как правило
обычно довольствуются те люди которые
преданы какой-то идее которые в принципе
счастливы им много не надо и они
довольствуются тем что есть таких людей
Обычно на переговорах прогнуть
невозможно потому что они знают чётко
что хотят и они никогда не прогнуться
второе у кого есть сила На чьей стороне
сила сила на стороне сила у того На чьей
стороне больше ресурсов в виде власти
Славы денег Ну или прочих ресурсов
заметьте сила на той стороне На чьей
стороне больше ресурсов это ещё Наполеон
сказал бог всегда на стороне больших
батальонов третий источник силы На чьей
стороне сила у того на кого работает
время вы тоже наверное очень много
замечали что сила у того на кого
работает время понятно что сила у
молодого нежели у старого потому что у
старого человека время работает против
него у молодого человека время работает
на него и очень даже легко предсказать
кто больших высот достигнет у старого
человека Всё уже позади А у молодого
человека всё ещё впереди Поэтому у него
На него работает время или простой
совсем банальный пример приведу вам вы
хотите пойти в туалет а туалет платный 5
долларов и вы говорите Вы что обнаглели
что ли туалет 5 долларов
я можно я быстро по малому схожу а там
вахтёр говорит Нет вы говорите Ну это же
очень дорого вы что за тлет 5 долларов
ну вахтёр говорит Ну хорошо не
устраивает не заходите вы пошли
покрутили сделали Круг вас уже так
поджимает потому что время работает
против вас вы приходите уже согласны на
5 долларов он говорит 10 и чем это
закончится закончится тем что вы всё
равно Заплатите потому что время
работает Не на вас четвёртое источник
силы у кого сила в переговорах у того на
кого работают обстоятельства я в жизни
очень часто замечал такую ситуацию когда
А на человека работают обстоятельства и
ему легче продавливать своего оппонента
и такое случается сплошь и рядом бывает
а человек на хайпе когда вот а ну вы
даже наверное сами замечаете когда
какой-то человек на хайпе А даже власти
ему навстречу идут и Ну например
Представьте такую ситуацию парень спас
там детей или какую-то семью или там
девушку и так далее И вот в социальных
сетях разлетелся его поступок А на хайпе
он герой дня власти дарят ему квартиру а
в аналогичной же ситуации но при котором
не было хайпа парня просто поблагодарили
и дали Или дали благодарственное письмо
от Министерства чрезвычайных ситуаций
почему такое
благодарственное письмо разница на лицо
у второго парня обстоятельства были в
его пользу пятый источник силы - это то
на кого работает место Место определяет
силу тоже приведу тоже пример Ну
например возьмём А
из средневековья Если вы стоите на
возвышенности и вы лучник и предположим
вы стреляете из лука на 100 м и ваш
противник на 100 м но он находится внизу
ваша стрела будет лететь 150 м а его
Стрела вместо 100 будет лететь 70 м у
вас преимущество уже в два раза почему
только потому что вы находитесь в
правильном месте или возьмём другой
другой пример когда вы делаете какой-то
бизнес и вы это у вас это получается и
вы делаете условно в Соединённых Штатах
то ваш бизнес Может оцениваться в
миллиарды а ровно такой же бизнес
абсолютно идентичные Ну вот например в
Казахстане будет оцениваться там в 10
млн долларов или в 20 млн долларов Здесь
тоже прямо показатель сила у того кто
Находится в правильном месте шестой
источник силы силы - это тот сила У того
у кого есть альтернатива или у кого есть
Свобода выбора это Например А я очень
хорошо применил когда я продавал свою
сотовую компанию за 425 млн долларов
заметьте начальная цена была 170 млн
долларов я её продал за 425 млн долларов
компании Velcom российской компании
почему мне это удалось потому что у меня
были желающие МТС Velcom уком China
Mobile четыре претендента То есть у меня
был выбор А у них выбора не было потому
что на тот момент было всего две
лицензии на осуществление
а там или построение сотовой компании
поэтому а сила У того у кого есть
альтернатива либо у кого есть Свобода
выбора вспомните свои ситуации жизни
когда у вас не было выбора вы
чувствовали себя сильным а Напишите
пожалуйста в
комментариях те случаи когда вы
чувствовали себя слабым и когда вы
чувствовали чувствовали себя сильным
наверняка это одной из причин будет
связано с тем что у вас был выбор когда
вы были сильным и когда вы чувствовали
себя слабым у вас выбора не было Ну и
седьмой источник силы - это сила у того
кто Находится в безопасности Потому что
если вы находитесь под риском Если вы
находитесь в опасной ситуации то вам
честно говоря не до капризов Вам
приходится действовать по
обстоятельствам и вы реагируете на
обстоятельства то есть не вы
диктуется а обстоятельства диктуют вам
то чем заниматься поэтому седьмой
источник силы - это безопасность
большинство людей когда им говорят про
эффективные переговоры они почему-то
вспоминают про техники переговоров про
то как себя вести на переговорах О чём
говорить Как держать себя поза когда
приходить раньше позже рукопожатие
осанка и так далее и так далее я вам
скажу Не парьтесь Это всё мелочи это всё
косметика которая ни в коем случае не
увеличивает вашу силу Я много раз видел
ситуацию когда миллиардер приходил в
Драх шлёпа И в шортах а напротив него
сидел бизнесмен который хотел получить
инвестиции в галстуке и в пиджаке
миллиардер делал делал всё что хотел и
тот послушно выполнял его прихоти
миллиардер говорил давай встретимся
завтра или завтр Принеси компьютер там а
и записываю то что я говорю и Та сторона
выполняла то что он хочет поэтому
забудьте про техники Вы больше
запутается суеты Если вы будете знать
основу переговоров а основа переговоров
это то чёткое понимание Кто выигрывает
на переговорах
и Что является Ну как я сказал на
переговорах Выигрывает тот на чей
стороне сила и дальше что является
источником этой силы Если вы будете
знать это то вам в принципе больше
ничего не надо знать о переговорах Я
очень много размышляю по поводу того у
кого находится сила и если вы хотите
больше узнать об этой теме и вообще
понять как вести переговоры и как это
делаю я подписывайтесь на мой кана
ссылку я so